[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
DIANA DARKE: So
first of all, let
me explain why I even have
a right to a voice on Syria.
I've studied Arabic back
in the '70s at Oxford,
and have basically devoted
the rest of my life
to the Middle East.
So I began with 10 years working
for the British government.
So I saw the Middle
East through the lens
of the British government.
And then I switched
to British industry.
So I saw the Middle East through
the lens of British industry.
And then I became
completely independent
and started writing.
And so I've now written what?
About 16 books about
the Middle East,
mainly travel
guides, very detailed
cultural and social
travel guides.
So that's been my focus.
So I would call myself a Middle
East travel writer, ultimately.
And so the reason I wrote this
book was because I was actually
in Syria back in 2004,
commissioned to write a very
detailed guidebook to Syria.
And by chance, I found it
was possible for a foreigner
like me to come in and buy
a chunk of a UNESCO World
Heritage site.
And I thought, "That's crazy.
How can that possibly be?"
If that really is
going to be possible,
then I'm going to do it.
So of course, that was
before the revolution.
So I embarked upon
a scheme, which
I'm going to take you
through now on a journey,
basically, into Syria,
to show you the Syria
that I have learned to know.
I've known Syria
since the 1970s,
but obviously I
only became deeply
embedded in Syrian
society after buying
this house and everything
that happened there.
So the book is the journey
of the house, and interwoven
with that is the story of the
Syrian Revolution, how it grew
up, the complexities
of Syrian society,
with a lot of
background knowledge
about Islamic philosophy,
Islamic literature.
All of that is
woven into the story
to give you a rich appreciation
of what Islamic culture is all
about.
Because I do feel it's
very deeply misunderstood
in this country.
So to do that, I'm going to
first of all show you a map.
Geography is incredibly
important in Syria.
It's vital to understand where
Syria is, on the Eastern shore
there of the Mediterranean,
which tells you really
all you need to know.
Syria has always
been on a crossroads.
In all directions, it has
been a trading nation.
It has been the
crisscrossing of so many
different civilizations, going
right back to the earliest
times of man's history.
Every single civilization
has crisscrossed
across this region,
and that is what
has formed the Syrian identity.
It means that Syria
over the centuries
has become multicultural,
multireligious,
and multiethnic.
And that's what's resulted
in this very, very
complex Syrian society.
It's a kind of mosaic.
There are so many
different elements to it.
And in this map,
the darker areas
there are the areas currently
of conflict and displacement.
And the reason for that--
so the areas that
are not colored in
are basically desert.
That's how Syria works.
It has an eastern
area with desert,
which is where Syria's
oil and gas fields are.
But the rest of the area is
actually surprisingly green,
with mountain
chains, and forests.
And the population,
needless to say,
is of course mainly
concentrated therefore
into those more agricultural
and and livable areas.
Very, very little
of the population
actually lives in
those desert areas.
Because Syria is not
a tribal society.
It's very important
to understand that.
There's a massive difference
between Syria and Iraq.
Iraq is a very
tribal society, which
is one of the reasons it
disintegrated so badly
after the American invasion.
But Syria has never
been like that.
It's a very cohesive society,
very blended on many levels.
So just to show a
bit of the geography,
Damascus, the capital, is right
down here, very, very close
to the Lebanese border.
And that tells you, reminds you,
that of course this whole area
was under the Ottoman
Empire for 400 years.
And this whole area
was the province
of Syria, which included
Lebanon, Israel,
Jordan, and Palestine.
All of that area
was that was what
was called Natural Syria,
Greater Syria, which
of course then got carved up
after the First World War,
with all these, as you can see,
very unnatural-looking borders.
So historically,
Damascus therefore
has always had very
close links to Lebanon,
just like Aleppo
right up in the north
there has always had very
close links to Turkey.
And Aleppo, when it got
caught up in the war,
it was natural for it to
redevelop its trading routes
and relocate its
factories into Turkey,
just like so much of the
industry and businesses
around Damascus
relocated to Lebanon.
Then, it's important
to understand
how the different communities
fit together here.
Because they don't
necessarily fall neatly
into little categories.
So when people talk
about partitioning
Syria and this kind of thing,
it's just not going to work,
because Syria's not like that.
It's much more blended.
So although loosely
up in the north
you have what's generally
referred to as a Kurdish belt,
because about 15% of the
Syrian population is Kurdish,
and they've taken advantage of
the lawlessness, if you like,
of the last six years to carve
out a territory at the top
there for themselves.
Because the Syrian army,
President Assad's army,
simply withdrew, just
left the vacuum there.
So naturally the
Kurds, who'd always
been aspiring to a
kind of autonomy there,
just filled the vacuum
and started creating
their own zones up there.
But of course Turkey
was absolutely
not going to stand
for that, which
is why Turkey has now
entered the Syrian War,
and has carved out what it's
calling a safe zone right up
in the north there, to make sure
that the Kurds can't take over
that territory.
And they're making very sure.
And this fits in well with
President Trump's promise
to build big, beautiful safe
zones in Syria, which he'll get
the Gulf countries to pay for.
So that will be
interesting to watch,
whether he succeeds
in doing that.
And of course, the
other big players
in the Syrian war at the
moment are Russia and Iran.
Now, Russia's interest in
Syria is economic and military.
It has always supplied
the Syrian armed forces
with their weaponry, going
right back to the '50s.
But economic because
it has signed already
a huge oil deal for the
as-yet unexcavated oil
offshore there on Syria's
Mediterranean coast.
So it signed a 25 year
deal to have the rights
to drill for oil there.
And of course, Syria has
also given it the opportunity
to reenter the world stage.
And Iran, Iran's huge
interest in the Syrian War
is to expand the Shia
Crescent, as it's
known, across into southern
Lebanon, into Hezbollah,
its financed and trained
armed militia, which
is a very, very powerful
player in Lebanon
and in Lebanese
politics these days.
So you've got all these
different complexities.
The overwhelming
population of Syria
is Sunni Arab, which is
the conventional mainstream
Arab grouping, largely a
very tolerant kind of Islam
completely opposite
to ISIS, which is what
has of course taken hold there.
And ISIS, when ISIS appeared on
the scene and took over Raqqa,
their headquarters, which you
see the big lake up there,
and that river is the Euphrates
River running off into Iraq,
Raqqa is the first
town after that lake.
And when ISIS, nearly
three years ago now,
it's worth remembering
just how long ago that was.
Three years ago, when
ISIS took over Raqqa,
everybody thought,
including Assad himself,
"Well, what does that matter?
It's a provincial backwater.
Nobody cares at all."
But they were very
clever in doing that.
Because by taking over Raqqa,
they were very cleverly
taking control of the main
water source for Syria,
the main hydroelectric
dam, which
is on that lake, and
of course, very quickly
took over the oil and gas
fields, which, as I mentioned,
were in that eastern area.
So right from the
start, they were
able to exert an unnatural
degree of control
over Syria's infrastructure.
And then the
Christian population
is about between 10% and 15%.
It's very difficult to
get accurate figures.
And they are scattered
all over the country.
And then you have other
strange minorities,
like the Druze,
who are scattered
in these areas to the south,
but also across the cities.
Just like the Kurds are also not
just in the north but scattered
all around.
So it's a very blended society.
So nowhere illustrates
this blending more
to my mind than the
old city of Damascus,
which is where I bought
my house, obviously.
And this map is in the
book, and it shows the walls
around the old city, which are
still intact, six kilometer
circumference, and
all the gateways,
the Roman gateways there, eight
of them all around the edges,
are still intact,
are still in use.
You can get a sense as you
walk through Damascus of layer
upon layer of civilization.
And so everywhere
has built on top
of the previous civilization.
So the military
headquarters for example,
that castellated building up
in the top left hand corner
has always been the military
headquarters of the city.
So back in Roman times, it
was the Roman castrum, where
these troops were garrisoned.
Then in the Middle Ages, it was
the place from which Saladin
masterminded the Crusades.
And in more recent history, it's
been used by the Assad regime
as a military prison.
And the street running
across the center
there is the biblical
street called Straight,
which is the street
that St. Paul was
let along when he was blinded
and fell from his horse.
He was led along
that street and up
into the Christian
quarter, where
he was cured of his sight.
And that the spiritual
heart of the center
is that big mosque image there,
in the center at number 11.
That has always been the
spiritual heart of the city.
So it began as a temple
to a weather god,
under the Arameans.
And then when the
Greeks came, they
turned it into a temple of Zeus.
And then the Romans turned
it into a temple of Jupiter.
And then the
Christians turned it
into a cathedral of
John the Baptist.
And John the Baptist's head is
still buried in that building.
And then when the Muslims
came in the 7th century,
they too wanted to use that same
space as their spiritual place
of worship.
And so they came to an
arrangement with the Christians
to share the building.
And so they entered through
the same main entrance,
the old temple entrance.
And the Christians turned
one way and the Muslims
turned the other.
And that arrangement
only came to an end
when they ran out of space.
And then the Muslims
said to the Christians,
"Right, we would like now
to take over this whole area
and make it into our
main mosque of the city.
And in exchange, we'll give you
land for four new churches."
So that's what happened.
And to this day,
those churches are
amongst these 17 churches
in the Christian quarter
there in the top section,
which are all still working,
all still functioning
in Damascus now.
And so on a Sunday
morning, you hear
church bells ringing
out across the city,
mingling with the
call to prayer.
That is how Damascus has always
been-- incredibly blended.
And the house which
I bought back in 2005
is down there, at
number one on the map.
And that is in a
Sunni-Shia mixed area.
So the building I've
just been describing,
that spiritual heart of
Damascus, looks like this now.
This is the mosque that
the Muslims built back
in the 7th century.
And you can see straight
away how blended that
is, just looking at
it, with the dome
there, which is reminiscent
of the Byzantine style
of architecture,
and the gable there
taken from the
Hellenistic period.
And then the tall
minaret there, which
could be a bell tower
or a church spire,
is in fact called
the Jesus Minaret.
Because local
tradition has it that
on the final day
of judgment, Christ
will descend from that minaret.
So this is very typical of
the natural blending of all
the traditions in Damascus.
And it's normal at Christmas
and Easter for Muslims
to go into the churches, and
it's normal for Christians
to go into the mosques.
All the mosques in Syria
are open to everybody.
You can go in there.
I spent hours in the
courtyard of this mosque,
just sitting there.
You can have a picnic.
People just enjoy themselves.
Children run around, treat
it like a playground.
It's a very, very relaxing,
like a kind of a safe haven.
This is the same building
in the depths of winter.
Because it's easy to forget that
Damascus is actually very high.
It's at 800 meters.
And so in the winter, I took
this picture actually just
in winter of last
year, in January,
when the temperature
dropped to minus 15.
So snow of this
type is not unusual.
And the reason I'm showing it to
you is that in Damascus itself,
there is no actual fighting
going on at the moment.
The fighting is
all in the suburbs.
The center is safe, because
it's so tightly under the grip
of the Assad regime.
But the infrastructure
problems, which
I explained are largely
to do with ISIS,
affect even the
center of Damascus.
So even in the center,
where there's no fighting,
they still only have about three
or four hours of electricity.
They have almost no gas,
almost no no heating fuel.
And the water supply
gets regularly blockaded
by rebel groups up in the
hills, in the mountains where
the main source comes from.
And so at this point,
all these water tanks,
those red tanks there are
water tanks on the roof.
And all of them
burst at that time,
which was an absolute
catastrophe for people
living in Damascus.
But the way Syrians
deal with this,
and this is another very
important thing, is they laugh.
They have this incredible
uncomplaining aspect to them.
They just accept whatever
is thrown at them,
and they don't let
it get them down.
They actually laugh about it.
So a friend of
mine rang recently,
and was laughing
and saying, "Oh, I
was woken up at
3:00 in the morning
by the sound of the water
pump pumping the water up
onto the roof.
And so I leapt out
of bed and rushed
to the shower, because
I knew that that
was going to be the
only time that month
when both the water
and the electricity
were both on together.
So it was going to
be my only chance
to wash my hair that month."
And they just laugh about this.
They just don't complain at all.
Now, this is the facade
of that same mosque.
And I'm showing you this because
this is one of the earliest
examples of Islamic art.
And you can see straight
away that the imagery
of it, the iconography is
also very blended aspect.
They've taken in aspects of
Christianity and the earlier
Hellenistic civilizations.
But what it's aiming to
do, like most Islamic art,
is to project a
vision of paradise.
And say the iconography tends
to be trees, and gardens,
and fantasized
buildings and rivers.
But the echoes of
Christianity come in
with the triple arched window.
You know, the echoes
of the Trinity there,
and the columns here, taken
from the classical sites, which
they'll have seen all
over Syria as well.
And the damage that is
from a random shell.
As I mentioned, the
center of Damascus
is basically safe, but
every now and again
a random shell is fired
in from the suburbs that
just happens to land somewhere.
And this one landed
on that facade.
But it's been repaired already.
The quality of Syrian
craftsmen is phenomenal,
and it's been repaired to
a very, very high standard.
I checked when I was last there,
and it has been all repaired.
So unfortunately, the
suburbs of Damascus--
completely different story.
They've just been pulverized
by the Assad government
for having the temerity
to stand up against him
and to ask for freedoms
and for reforms
to his highly corrupt system,
which is completely gripped
by a security state, basically.
For the last 45,
50 years, Syria has
been under the grip
of the Assad family,
and there's been no such
thing as free speech, largely.
I mean, if you
dared to criticize
the system in any way, you'd
be plucked off the streets
and you'd disappear into prison.
And so people learned
to be quiet, basically.
They learned to be silent.
And so I refer quite
a lot in the book
to the silent majority.
Because at the
moment, most Syrians
fall into that category.
They are the silent majority.
They're not with Assad,
and they're not with ISIS,
obviously.
They are stuck between
these two extremes.
And that's what's so tragic
about their situation.
So at this time, when all the
suburbs were being pulverized,
this is when a lot of my friends
started to lose their homes.
And so this is
the point at which
I offered them my house to
come and stay as a safe haven.
Now, of course this
is the sort of image
that the media is
always showing us.
And the media is a topic I
want to touch on, because it
is important to understand.
Because almost all our
perceptions about what's
going on in Syria
come from the media,
whether we like it or not.
And so it's all a question
of what media we look at,
and what we allow
to influence us.
And of course, ISIS
have a head of media.
He's a 33-year-old
Syrian-American.
He's a genius, and
they pay him a fortune
to produce very, very
clever images like this,
which project this massive sense
of power, of the power of ISIS.
And of course, here they're
using the stage building
of the Roman theater in
Palmyra to project this image
onto the world stage
of their power.
And so they've lined up a
group of Syrian soldiers there.
And behind them
are teenagers, who
are about to be the soldiers.
And they've been sending
out 90,000 tweets a day,
with something like
30,000 Twitter accounts.
Very, very active.
And they completely
were way, way ahead
of any other force
involved in this war.
So they were able to
project the amount of power
that they had quite
disproportionately.
And of course, what they were
seeking to destroy in Palmyra
is precisely what
I've been explaining
about this blended
multicultural society.
Because Palmyra, a
caravan city in the middle
of the desert there, all
along the trading routes,
because it's been Rome on
its eastern fringe there,
it's where Rome blended with
the Babylonian and Mesopotamian
cultures and with
the Persian cultures
and with the ancient
Egyptian cultures, and that
resulted in a special
fusion of the cultures
to create the Palmyran
civilization, which is unique.
It had its own language.
They had their own style
of dress, their own hair
styles, their own
jewelry, all of which
shows in their statues.
And that's precisely of course
what ISIS wanted to destroy.
So of course, that
building that we just saw
was blown up like that in
an image, which they then
tweeted all around the
world, to again show
how powerful they were.
But of course,
it's not only ISIS
who's been using the Syrian
War as a propaganda tool.
Russia and Putin have.
It's been an
absolute gift to him.
And if you watch
Russian TV, which
I do quite a lot these
days, RT on Freeview,
you know channel 1, 3,
5, anybody can get it.
It's such an eye opener to see
how misinformation is done.
Very, very clever.
So of course when Russia took
retook Palmyra from ISIS.
They immediately saw
what a propaganda coup,
this was because the world
has always been fascinated
by the mystique of Palmyra.
And so Russia bused in a special
orchestra for this victory
concert in the very same
building, the Roman theater,
that ISIS was doing
its staged beheading.
Russia is now doing its
staged victory concert.
It forced people to come into
the audience, along with some
of its own soldiers.
And then Putin has himself
put in on a video link
to project himself to the
world as the savior of Syria,
the defender of terrorism.
And it's very clever
stuff, and it works.
Because what we
didn't hear about at
all is what was going on
in Palmyra before Russia
and before ISIS.
Because these pictures
are from 2013, well
before any of that
happened, when in fact
this damage was caused by
the Syrian government itself,
because it was firing on a small
group of rebels who had set up
a small headquarters inside
the temple of Ba'al, which
has big, high walls, so
it's quite fortified.
So it made a natural
defensive spot.
But the Syrian
government thought
nothing of going up onto the
hill that overlooks the site
and shelling its own
cultural heritage
and causing all
this destruction.
And you can see here, these
are Syrian tanks moving around
within the ruins, heavy trucks.
They put a multiple
rocket launcher
in the temple of Diocletian.
They didn't think
twice about it.
But these pictures were taken
very secretly on the ground
by Syrian activists
who recorded it.
Because of course Assad
has been very, very careful
to make sure that journalists
don't get in to Syria.
These days, you have
Russian journalists
and Iranian journalists,
who cover the angles
that they want covered.
And it was very, very clear
during the Aleppo campaign
that that's precisely
what was going on.
The Assad regime doesn't
invite journalists
in unless it's got something
that wants to show them,
which it did just before
the fall of Aleppo.
Because it wanted
to show them exactly
at that moment how
the city was falling
and how they were providing
was humanitarian aid.
And then, of course,
it makes them all
go out again before
the ugly end game,
when it then bombs the place
completely into smithereens.
So it's very, very
tightly controlled.
I mean, Syria has for the
last five years in a row
topped the bill of the
most dangerous place
for journalists.
Because there is
no free journalism
from international outlets.
So Syrian activists have
trained themselves up.
They have people
who were not at all
in that field who have
become photo journalists
and activists on the ground.
So this is another one of
Syria's UNESCO World Heritage
sites.
This is the Krak de Chevaliers.
It's the world's best
preserved crusader castle,
and it's got caught up in the
conflict for the same reason
that Palmyra got caught up--
its strategic location.
Because the reason it's
there in the first place,
just like the reason Palmyra's
is because of the trade
trade routes converging.
Here, the castle
is guarding what's
called the Homs Gap, which is
a natural break in the mountain
chain, the only break from
the inside interior desert
to the coast.
And so strategically it's
a very important place.
And so at the start of the
revolution , a group of rebels,
and with the full consent
of the local villagers,
took up a position inside.
And of course the
Syrian Air Force
immediately came and
bombarded it from above.
And it's one of those many
ironies in the Syrian War,
that so much of its
cultural heritage
has come through unscathed.
I mean, this castle was
never taken throughout.
It was built in
the 12th century.
It was never taken, it was
never damaged until now,
when it got bombed by
its own government.
Other sites get caught up
for their strategic location.
So this is a monastery right
up on the top in the Qalimun
mountains at 2,000 feet.
It's 2,000 meters high.
Right on the border
between Lebanon and Syria.
And so this ministry,
the Syrian government
came in and kicked out
the monks and took over.
And again, you can see how the
monastery there was originally
a Greek temple, all the
style, the size of the blocks.
All of this is Hellenistic
masonry with the columns there.
So it's another example of an
ancient site which has evolved
with each new civilization.
So the monks have
been kicked out,
and it's been turned
into an army barracks.
Because strategically, they
want to come on the high points
up there.
But you then get
cases like this.
This is another
church in Ma'loula.
And some of you may
have heard of Ma'loula.
It's always paraded in
the press as the place
where the language of Christ,
Aramaic, is still spoken.
But Ma'loula is of no
strategic interest to anybody.
It's tucked into a little
cleft down in the mountains.
It doesn't command
anything at all.
And this is a classic case
of media manipulation.
Because the timing of this was
just before, if you remember,
there was that big
chemical attack,
chemical weapons attack
in the east of Damascus.
And that almost led Obama to
intervene in the Syrian case.
And it really did
look at one stage
as if Obama was going to enter.
His red line had
been crossed, and he
was going to actually
intervene and bomb Assad.
And Assad was so worried at that
point that this might really
happen, and that this
would be the end of him,
that he engineered a crisis
here in Ma'loula, knowing that
the world would pay attention
to what happens in Ma'loula.
And so he engineered
an attack like this,
and then showed it to
the media, and showed
his own army coming in
to save the inhabitants,
and the nuns and the
monks in the village.
This is a monastery,
a famous monastery
that's been burned out.
And he said, "Look,
if you get rid of me,
look what's going to happen.
Terrorism will run
over the whole country.
I am the only defender
of the minorities here."
And of course, it worked.
It worked.
Obama backed off.
The parliament here didn't
vote to go along with it.
And afterwards, the
nuns in the village
actually said "The
army, the Syrian army,
sold us to the media."
It was a clear case.
And again, this
is another example
of where Western journalists
were invited in to be shown.
"look, look.
Look at this destroyed church.
Look what will happen
if you get rid of me."
And it's very effective.
It works.
And this is in Homs.
This is another church
in Homs, again bombarded
by aerial bombardment.
You may remember
it so long ago now.
This seems to have
been going on so long,
that in 2012, when
all this was going on,
this is where Marie Colvin, the
Sunday Times journalist, where
she was killed, when the
center of the old city of Homs
was being aeriel
bombarded and completely,
completely destroyed.
And that was the first
of the many starve
or surrender sieges,
basically, where the whole area
was completely destroyed.
So to get down to the personal
level now with the house,
I'll just show you a
few images of the house.
This, as the map
showed, is in the center
of the old city of Damascus.
So this is within the
UNESCO World Heritage site.
It's a courtyard house.
Damascus has the world's
largest collection
of old residential
Ottoman architecture.
So this house dates back.
It's blended, like
everything in Syria.
It's blended between the 17th,
18th, and 19th centuries.
Different sides of the courtyard
are from different centuries,
because it's been
continuously inhabited
so it's already come through
wars, invasions, earthquakes,
fires, all of that.
And so the city has been
constantly being rebuilt.
And so you can see it looks
in a pretty sorry state here.
It was actually inhabited
when I bought it.
And it was just about
possible to live there.
So this is now
August of 2005 when
the temperature is 40 degrees.
And so I was semi-camping
in the house,
waiting for the
bureaucracy to kick in.
So this was my first real
exposure to Syrian bureaucracy
and how everything works.
And Syrian bureaucracy
is like a labyrinth.
It combines the
worst of the Ottoman
and the worst of the French.
And so my task now
was to find myself
a bank manager, who turned
out to be a Christian lady.
I had to find
myself a lawyer, who
turned out to be a Sunni Kurd.
I had to find myself
an architect, who
was a Sunni Arab.
And the architect and
I gathered together
a team of about 15
Syrian craftsmen
to embark on the
restoration project, which
took three years.
So this is what we had
to do at the start.
We had to rip off all of those
walls around the courtyard,
were covered with a
white, uniform cement
masking everything underneath.
And that in the
book becomes a kind
of metaphor for
the Assad regime,
which has been suffocating
the true nature of Syria
and its true identity
for the last 50 years.
And so the first thing we
had to do was pull that off.
And what we found underneath
was these mud bricks, which
I call the mud of Mesopotamia.
Because this mud and
this style of house
goes right back to the
earliest Mesopotamian times.
It's evolved to be perfectly
adapted to the climate.
And these mud bricks keep
the heat in the winter
and the heat out in the summer.
And so this is like
a perfect eco-house.
In fact, this arch
here is the open iwan,
as it's called, that
faces onto the courtyard,
always north facing, so
that when you sit there
in the summer, the sun never
shines directly into it,
and it always
catches the breezes.
So it is perfectly
evolved for the climate.
You don't need air
conditioning in these houses.
So this is in the depths
of the restoration.
This is absolute chaos, as
you can see, everything.
It doesn't look as
if anything is ever
going to get any better.
But the extraordinary
thing about this period
was that all of us
really enjoyed ourselves.
We all knew what we
were striving for.
So again, this is
the state that Syria
is locked in at the moment.
It's completely chaotic.
It doesn't look as if it's
ever going to get any better,
and yet the people inside
Syria who have stayed
behind are remarkably cohesive.
I've seen it firsthand.
And so here is the
electrician, who
is coming across with the kettle
to have one of our many tea
breaks.
You can see all
the glasses there,
the tea glass glasses lined up
along the side of the fountain.
And this is some
of the detailing
of the interior and the rooms.
So you can see
this dates to 1700.
This is what I call
the [? Ajami ?] room.
This is hand painted
wooden lacquer work.
And you can see
again how they've
taken in elements from
earlier civilizations.
That gold acanthus
leaf up in the corner
there is straight off the
Hellenistic blocks of Palmyra.
And the iconography
again is gardens--
gardens, flowers, little
birds hidden in the trees.
And on those green
panels, that is not
inscriptions from the Quran.
That is a Sufi poem, Sufism
being the mystic Islam.
Syrian Islam is
very close to that.
It's a very kind of moderate,
tolerant version of Islam.
And this is a Sufi poem
invoking blessings on the house
and on the owner.
And this is another
detail of the interior.
This is what I refer to as
the secret ceiling, which
comes to represent a
tapestry of Syrian society,
the way all the different
elements are blended together.
And again, you
can see hark-backs
to the earlier civilizations.
So things like that, that
is the rose of Palmyra,
taken straight off the
carved blocks of Palmyra.
And you can see how
strangely familiar
that looks in some ways, because
that top and bottom borders
there could be taken straight
from a William Morris catalog.
It could be curtains, curtain
material or wallpaper.
And that's no accident.
That's because British
architects went out to Palmyra
and did detailed drawings
back in the 18th century
of the patterns that
they found in Palmyra,
brought them back to this
country, published them,
and that stimulated the
neoclassical revival
in this country, which is
why we see this kind of thing
all over our country
houses all across Britain.
And here again,
this would have been
covered with the white uniform
cement that I'm talking about.
But in removing that, of
course, you cause damage.
And if you can see that hole
up there, just to the left,
there's a big hole in
the stonework there.
I took a very conscious
decision with the restoration
of the house not
to over-restore,
not to aim for some sort
of unnatural perfection,
but to leave that kind of thing.
Because if you like,
it's a kind of scar,
just like Syria will have
to take in many, many scars
and absorb them, and look them
in the eye, actually, and say,
"Right, this is damage
which has been done,
but we have to now
absorb that and make it
part of our future identity."
And in the blending again
that I've mentioned,
right at the very top there,
quite difficult to see,
but there is actually
what we would
think of as a Jewish
star of David,
in two interlocking triangles
right at the top there.
But in Damascus,
that has nothing
to do with a specifically
Jewish symbol.
That is actually locally
known as shield of Solomon.
And again, it's just a
symbol to protect the house.
So at the end of three years,
this is what we ended up with--
everything perfectly restored.
Wherever there were
things missing,
like for example the
little bronze heads there
in the fountain, we
would go to salvage
yards around the outskirts
of the city and source
them from there.
So the only new things
that came into this house
were the infrastructure,
just as in Syria,
that's what has to happen.
The faulty wiring, if you
like, and the faulty drains
and plumbing, all of that
has to be ripped out.
Just like in the Assad regime,
the corrupt and malfunctioning
bureaucracy of the security
state, of the torture
systems, all of
that and the people
who've got their
fingers in all the pies
at the top, all of that
has to be ripped out.
And then Syria can
be what it should be,
this multilayered, very, very
beautiful and complex society.
But moving on now
to ISIS again, one
of the things that's been
happening all over Syria
is looting of the
cultural heritage.
And ISIS has again seen
in the cultural heritage
an opportunity to make money.
And of course, it's making
money because the oil
that it's been controlling, it
has tacit under the table deals
with the Assad regime.
So Assad continues to buy
oil from his own oil wells
through ISIS, and then
they just take a rake off.
Just like with the
cultural heritage
here, they take a
rake off of 20%,
and the stuff gets fed onto
the international art market.
But every now and
again, when they dig up
something so massive,
like this 7th century
BC Assyrian statue,
of course that's
far too huge to be passed
off on the art market.
So they use it instead
for propaganda purposes,
and they publicly
smash it to bits,
and then tweet it
all around the world
to, again, make themselves
seem so powerful.
And they force the
local population
to come and watch this.
So if you can see the expression
on that little boy's face,
who's being made to watch his
own cultural heritage being
destroyed like that,
it's just pure agony.
Because Syrians care
very, very deeply
about their cultural heritage.
It's like having part
of their soul erased.
And Aleppo, this is Aleppo
before the fall of it,
obviously.
So this is as it used to be,
Syria's commercial hub, one
of the most famous souks in
the whole of the Arab world,
and then afterwards
when it caught fire.
And the reason it
caught fire was
because, again, the government,
the Syrian government,
shelled a rebel headquarters
in the old city.
And it hit an
electricity substation.
That caught fire, spread
through all the shops.
And overnight, 40,000
people were made bankrupt.
But of course, what
we don't hear about
is what Syrians are doing
on the ground about this.
And this is a picture of
two archeology students
from Aleppo University.
And nobody's paying
them to do this.
They are volunteers.
And they are, of
their own accord,
building a protective
wall in front
of the shrine of Zechariah,
the tomb of Zechariah, who's
the father of John the Baptist.
And his tomb is inside
the Aleppo Umayyad mosque.
And this is happening
all over Syria.
Syrians on the ground
are trying to protect
in whatever way they can
their own cultural heritage.
And the same thing
here, this is right down
in the south, another one of
Syria's UNESCO World Heritage
sites.
This is Basra, one of the
world's best preserved
Roman amphitheaters.
And you should never be
misled by what people
look like in the Syrian War.
Because you could look at that
group of people there and think
there were a bunch
of jihadi extremists,
but in fact, the guy in
the middle with a red beard
is the local
history teacher, who
set up a revolutionary
antiquities department.
And the people around him are
in charge of the local militias,
where they have gathered
together the local population
to protect the city.
Because when they saw
what happened in Palmyra,
they all vowed that this was
not going to happen to Basra.
And so to end with
now, just this
is a picture of some of the
families who were in my house
as I mentioned, when
they lost their own homes
around the outside.
I invited them to move in.
And so I had five families,
different families,
living in the house.
Obviously I wasn't
there anymore.
I'd come back to this country.
And of course it's
very difficult.
Five families who don't
know each other, all
having to share the same house.
Some were virtually illiterate.
Some were university educated.
So it's not a natural blend.
They've only got one
kitchen, two bathrooms,
and there are lots of
arguments about who
was paying the electricity,
to who was paying the water.
Because believe
it or not, people
are still expected
to pay the bills,
even in the middle of the war.
So there was a lot of
arguing and aggravation
in the first couple of months.
But then all that settle
down, when they gradually
got used to each other.
And the wonderful thing
was that they ended up
the best of friends.
And so these four
children are actually
from four different families,
who have stayed very, very
close to each other.
And this is one of
the things about war.
One has to realize
that although all we
see on the screens the whole
time is the awfulness of war,
the damage, war pushes
you out of your comfort
zone in a way that can be
actually very productive.
And a lot of my friends in
Syria, about half of whom
are still inside the
country, the other half
are scattered around
Turkey, Jordan, Lebanon,
and some of them have
made it to Germany,
they all feel that this has
been an incredible experience
for them.
They've all done things
that they would never
have dreamt of doing.
So they've got themselves
new qualifications.
They've entered fields they
would never have done before.
A lot of the women,
for example, I
mean, there are far fewer
women, with far too many women
almost in Damascus these days.
Because so many of the men
have left or been killed.
And so the women are
finding themselves,
rather like with the world
wars in this country,
being forced to go out and do
things that they would never
have done ordinarily.
So there have been many, many
positives to the whole thing.
So I just want to end by saying
that the book actually supports
a special charity for a
special fund for Syrian higher
education, so that Syrians
who've had their university
studies interrupted can
continue them outside of Syria.
Because the vital thing is
that at the end of all of this
that there must be an elite
of highly trained Syrians
who can bring the country back.
Because Syria is such a
gifted society, and so many
of our inventions come from
that part of the world,
going right back
to the alphabet,
the first musical notation
was invented there, so
many scientific inventions.
The list is almost endless--
the division of minutes
into 60, 60 minutes
in an hour and 60 seconds.
Massive numbers
of things actually
come from this
part of the world.
It's a highly creative society.
Steve Jobs was an
obvious example,
whose birth father was Syrian.
They have a natural
adaptability.
It's part of the culture,
part of the identity
because they've always
had this blending.
It's a real argument for
multiculturalism, in my view.
It shows that because
of all that blending,
you can become a
much richer society.
And that's how Syrian
society always has been,
and remarkably still
is, although you
don't hear about it.
It's still very, very cohesive.
And so it deserves
all our support.
So try to remember when you hear
the news, that in the middle
there is this silent
majority of the vast majority
of the Syrian population
who are currently
stuck between Assad
and ISIS, who of course
never have fought each other.
That's the massive
irony in this.
They've never fought each other.
They've just been
intent on wiping out
the moderate Syrian
opposition in the middle.
And that's why we're in this
tragic situation at the moment.
But as I said, it's not it's
not entirely without hope.
Because I do think that there
will be a massive rebirth
at the end of all of this.
Thanks very much.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER 1: Thanks very much.
Thank you very much, Diana.
This is an incredible talk on
a very, very timely subject.
And we have a few
minutes for questions
if anyone would like to ask one.
AUDIENCE: Thank
you for the talk.
I actually had two
maybe linked questions.
The first is, after
the death of someone
like Assef Shawkat, the
sanctions against Rami
Makhlouf, what does the
inner circle around Assad
look like now?
Like, how strong is he?
And perhaps there's a link
to that-- after the gassing,
if the Americans and coalition
forces had intervened
at that point, do you think
we could have toppled Assad
and would something
better be in his place?
DIANA DARKE: Well, just to
start with the last one,
I have been consistently
of the view that we should
have intervened, actually
even before that,
the chemical attack.
I think we should have gone in
right in the summer of 2011,
when the Syrians were
begging us to come in,
and when we'd gone into Libya.
And so that's what gave them
the courage to actually stand up
and to go out on all their
peaceful demonstrations.
Because, again, it's
worth remembering
that for the first four to
six months, it was peaceful.
The demonstrations
were peaceful.
But they just got shot.
They just got gunned down.
Peaceful demonstrators
got gunned down.
That's what turned the whole
thing into an armed uprising.
But then when the Free Syrian
Army rose up spontaneously
that first summer in
2011, mainly made up
of defectors from
Assad's army, they
were begging us to come in.
"Come in.
Please help us.
Make a safe zone along the
Turkish border where we can go
and where we can be protected."
If we had done that,
then, ISIS would never
have existed, because ISIS
didn't come along until 2013.
The vacuum was
there for two years.
But we did nothing.
And so ISIS would not have been
able to get its toehold there
in Syria.
It meant The whole refugee
crisis would not have existed.
There would be no need
for all those people
to come to Europe, to
destabilize Europe, and all
the terrorism and
everything that we now
associate with Syria.
None of that needed to happen.
And as for his
inner circle, this
is a very, very
interesting question.
I mean, so many people
have said "Surely, surely,
somebody is going
to assassinate him."
After that bomb in which
Assef Shawkat was killed,
that was the moment at which
a lot of my Syrian friends
thought, "Right.
That's it.
I've got to leave,
because we know now
it's going to get really ugly.
Because his retaliation for
that is going to be massive."
And so that is actually
when most of my friends
left and went to Turkey or
wherever, where they have now
carved out entirely new
lives for themselves.
But the interesting thing is
now, as the war has wound on,
and Assad has-- the only
reason Assad is still
there, of course, is because
Iran has been supporting him
to a massive degree.
They've been lending him money.
They've been training up this
massive paramilitary force
and the national defense forces.
100,000 people.
They're doing the
fighting, and Hezbollah.
The Syrian army itself
has been so weakened.
It's really, really weak.
It would have fallen.
But even with all
that help from Iran,
it would still have fallen.
And Russia could see
that, which is why it then
came into the war as well,
just over a year ago,
to make sure that
Assad didn't fall.
I mean, the man would have been
gone by now if it hadn't been.
And this is without our help.
We did nothing.
They got very little
help, the moderate rebels.
We did nothing.
And Assad had all
the help from Iran,
all that help from Russia.
It's a miracle, frankly, that
there's still anything left
of the Syrian opposition.
But it is still there.
And it's not going to go away.
So all this stuff
about maybe Assad
is the lesser of two evils
is just so shortsighted.
There's no way.
And people forget that
the deaths in Syria,
close to half a million, it's
very difficult to document them
and the UN stopped
counting so long ago,
but the deaths,
95% of the deaths
have been caused by
the Assad regime.
People imagine it's all ISIS.
ISIS has been responsible
for a tiny number of deaths.
It's all got
disproportionately--
We see it through
this lens of terrorism
now, that we're all so
frightened of the terrorism
that we think that
ISIS is the problem.
ISIS isn't the problem.
ISIS is the result
of the problem
that we didn't deal
with right at the start.
Yeah, but so tragically his
group is being held in position
by Iran and Russia.
And they're not
going to go away.
SPEAKER 1: So what's next
for Syrian people who
have gone to Europe?
What would be required to entice
these people to return to Syria
to help rebuild the country?
DIANA DARKE: Every
single Syrian I
know would go back to Syria like
a shot if it was safe for them
to do so.
Every single one.
I mean, it's remarkable how
they have such a deep connection
to their homeland, huge.
I mean, I've got friends
who've now been in Germany
for two to three years.
They've been taught German.
They've tried to integrate.
It's very difficult to get work.
They would go back.
They want to go back.
They're so closely in touch
with everything that's going on.
And so that is what gives
me hope, to be honest,
that it will rebuild.
It will rebuild.
And let's hope
that Trump manages
to build some big,
beautiful safe zones
and gets the Saudis
to pay for them.
Because that would be terrific,
if he could achieve that.
And Pigs might fly.
We'll see.
SPEAKER 1: And on
that note, please
join me in thanking Diana
Darke for her fabulous talk.
[APPLAUSE]